human beings should not be treated as
Pawns in a political game if you want to
deal with the problem
then do it if you are a leader by
does this look like a political game
Kamala well law enforcement sources say
a group of suspected cartel gunmen
armed with rifles and body armor were
seen on camera Crossing illegally into
the United States in front in Texas on
Saturday night Elite border patrol
Vortec agents were called out and they
searched the area but by them poof they
were gone joining me now is Vivek
ramaswamy Republican presidential
candidate Vivek um
we're told still by the left that it is
racist
to want a closed border so can we then
say you are pro-terrorist when you want
an open border because that looks like
what we're welcoming into the country in
addition to everyone else
an open border is not a border Laura and
I just think the remarkable thing right
now is that we are spending hundreds of
billions of dollars of military
resources to protect somebody else's
border from an invasion Halfway Around
the World when we have an invasion
literally now an armed Invasion across
our own Southern border that we're not
doing a thing about and what I think we
need in our foreign policy Laura is a
Revival of a modern Monroe Doctrine that
above all else if there's one purpose of
the U.S military it is to protect the
American Homeland to protect Americans
here on American soil whether that is a
Chinese spy balloon or a spy Base in
Cuba or now armed cartel gunman or
chinese-made fentanyl coming across the
southern border with Mexican drug
cartels yes we will use and are legally
and morally and ethically justified in
using our own military to secure our own
border rather than somebody else's
Border in Ukraine or any or else that's
the kind of leadership we need and
that's my plan as president
well you know a lot of Democrats now are
light bulb time trying to figuring out
what the heck is happening it's a
disaster for their states
fellow Democrats like we saw Adams of
New York the mayor and now Massachusetts
governor Maura Healy is having a change
of heart watch this then and now video
do you support Massachusetts becoming a
sanctuary State I think we have a system
that's working well here there are a
number of places that have adopted a
status as a sanctuary City and I think
that that is is working the increased
level of demand is not slowing down
expanding shelter at a rapid pace
and it's unsustainable
for this reason today I am declaring a
state of emergency in Massachusetts
Vivek these people are just Shameless it
was obvious from the beginning this was
going to be a catastrophe for regular
Working Class People and now they're
just getting it because what the Elites
in Boston are upset okay
that's exactly right now the donor class
that pulls the strings in both parties
has decided it's now inside the Overton
window to actually complain about the
southern border the problem is it is too
little too late and the fact is Laura
even the wall which they actually
criticized long ago most people are now
quietly on the side of the wall even
Democrats are that wall itself is
insufficient because they're building
tunnels underneath that wall that
they're driving trucks through so I
think we have to take the Bold step of
using our own military to see to seal
that swiss cheese of a southern border
that's how we end the fentanyl crisis
the human trafficking crisis the ten
thousand to fourteen thousand illegal
migrants per day that's going to take
courage that's what I think it takes an
outsider to deliver hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else